[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
did you talk to someone or you just
decide i like it's it's
like it's fully solid what somebody
who's
yeah this is a collab he did with uh yg
yg foe honey
and i love snoopy here's snoop's the new
judge on uh super gangster he's the new
judge on the voice
is he really yep isn't that what do you
think
what don't they like help people guide
people through
well they have there's like there's like
nick jonas what's up cat there's like
nick jonas
there's nick jonas there's uh
uh blake shelton and uh there's a girl
oh and then kelly clarkson i know but
don't
christina aguilera was on that show yeah
yeah and then the dude from room five
was on there adam yeah so that's where
they picked they pick a guy they're like
team they work
teams and they coach them and then they
compete
who's he who's going coaching isn't that
weird that is weird
make sure he's on the voice change
doesn't make sense at all but i'm pretty
sure he is
really that is weird who are we talking
about now
he's on the voice it's it's no it's not
american idol american idol is where the
real talents at
do you think that's where the real
talent is i know there's tons of people
on the board
oh you want to do this oh really names
name someone from the voice who who
who's done anything it's about the story
my dude with the guitar oh yeah yeah
yeah
the guy i know yeah he's not doing [ __ ]
he's doing weddings
what else you got how you know he
probably popping
he's not popping what's his name yeah
you introduce this to us he's like you
can see that's mega mentor on the voice
he's a mega mentor mega mentor what does
that mean so that means he's probably
just giving him advice
advice on like how to deal with her
career oh ariana grande just signed on
the voice she's the judge for this
she's gonna she's been on there though
really ariana oh ariana grande yeah
ariana oh i think you're sitting out
glare
oh yeah she was uh he has john legend
there i can't wait
him you know you don't like chrissy
teigen either right
i like chrissy oh really i like chris
john legend
not for you i don't get my real wait
where's that where's that guy at
with the guitar from the boys that was
good find him i'm telling you you're
barking up the wrong tree
cause i introduced you to him and i know
the guy and i know he's not popping
how are you gonna tell me about a guy
that i told you about
and i say name one and you mentioned him
he won
10 years ago but you said name one
you're probably on tick-tock killing him
he's probably killing it
he said the voice look at i remember him
yeah i think you yeah look at chris blue
i think he wants
look he wants to
[Applause]
hey jordan smith probably did some [ __ ]
too yup chris blue was definitely at the
uh yeah
when the fire and eisley brother you can
hire any of them for your wedding
yeah any of them they will show up 500
easy easy to reach out to 500 sundance
head will
show up to your [ __ ] barbecue
sundance
season 11 so that means he oh these are
the winners these are the winners yeah
yeah
sundance sundance name one name
one that you've heard of but wait we
gotta go to the runner-ups because on
the american idol
a lot of runners it's always a runner-up
you're saying you guys are parking
we're going nowhere here we're going i'm
telling you you guys don't know the show
no one no one does [ __ ] that's why they
always make fun of the voice
like american idol's for stars the voice
is like whatever well you know
i feel like the x factor they do more
those people do more i like that like
right with that am i am i right good
call so the x factor
was created and that's how american
island came about it's the same creator
oh same people same same thing okay
and you know actually x factor not
everyone's singing everyone's like
it's just talent show oh no ameri i was
thinking america's got talent people
come people pop off
that's kind of the x factor though yeah
it seems like the same world x factor is
not just singing right yeah they're like
juggling [ __ ] there's magicians
uh no i think x factor x factor's
english
english yeah but you're saying america's
got talent right yeah yeah america's got
talent
i mean you might get a show on vegas or
some [ __ ] again american idol building
straight
stars doug brooke people have sold out i
mean comedians that have done
america america's got talent selling out
tours but he's basically going to see
creature
and yeah and you're saying preacher got
big off america against town
did he win it uh lost to a girl who
played with dogs yeah
and he's been there he's been able to
really springboard off that he makes
sense
yeah what other comics uh sam uh sam uh
uh tourette's uh he's got tourette's
[ __ ]
and drew lynch drew lynch yeah he's
another one
those guys have been been able to bank
off and um
jackie fabulous
selling out arenas you talk about drew
lynch selling out the miami improv
i'm talking big boy [ __ ] here man but
singing in comedy we can't compare that
yeah
let's let's go to single let's take this
singer let's go okay so so far because
any comedian not every comedian is an
arena
comedian yeah like a lot of i mean it's
tough to become
here's my problem when you say popping
off i think our definition of popping
off is different
okay you're talking i'm talking big [ __ ]
man i'm not talking about
selling out an improv i'm talking like
millions and millions and millions of
dollars in fans opposed to selling out a
weekend in houston
damn well i mean he's lit
shut up just it depends what popping off
me
okay i i mean if you're headlining the
venice underground it means you made it
then yeah you pop it doug
no i'm not saying the venus underground
i don't know i'm saying these people
have
actually like have good tours you know
but but it's comedian
i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying but he was right
i'm not saying he's wrong no no he what
he did but
like like he gave them a crew like but
preacher was popping before that
no i'm sure he was doing decent he was
doing
he had stand up he was doing like
preachers or beasts six years
six and seven yeah he was only six years
in yeah but but he wasn't doing bad
no he wasn't doing he i mean yeah he was
it was it was a lunch it was a leaping
pad
it was it for sure helped okay that's
what we said but he's basically saying
craig i'm talking carry on dude i'm
talking
[ __ ] you money i'm talking carrie
underwood she got [ __ ] you money yeah
absolutely carrie underwood yeah okay
what
i don't know what to do
i agree with you that guy juggling
you're telling me
no that nope nope it's a launching board
i guess
yeah but american is just different it's
on 20 seasons
like usually but you fall in love with
those people you have to like it's like
what two months is a two months
but who's who's the last person from
america and i know that really pop thank
you that's a great question uh
two seasons ago alejandro he sells out
like you know how you're saying sell out
he like he's he has a huge following is
he is he got runner up
no what kind of musician would you say
he is jen um
just like with pop i wouldn't say he's
so talented it's like
that's a good question like i said r b
pop he's like he's like an indie r
b pop like like he kind of has his own
lane when it comes to
super talks about them a lot so
i don't talk about that much i probably
reference a year because i could educate
these [ __ ]
i'm not hurting that's fair every time
you talk about american idol you talk
about him and it's usually about
but when people say they don't know who
he is like yeah he's
he's super talented it's a question it
goes what happened to american idol
alejandro so he's
is he still doing great i'll go to his
instagram
i mean before the pandemic every toy he
had is sold out so
again it depends what you mean popping
me yeah okay now is he kevin hart
i don't know 633 oh i remember this guy
i don't remember him i remember this guy
he he like amazing so he's just like we
can sweep a tour now
actually
yeah i think what's tough is uh american
idols
are yeah american idol is kind of like
the ultimate fighter like you're into
this weird contract
oh yeah that's right oh you didn't
explain that so like carrie underwood
didn't like start making [ __ ] you money
till she got out of that deal notice how
she doesn't [ __ ] with american health at
all
but she don't come back for [ __ ] most
people who win don't
uh i didn't realize that there was a
contract on great place
[ __ ] i carry underwear and
shit's like that's how you get your
start girl jordan
jordan sparks spoke about that as well
she was like i hated the worst contract
i had was american idol
damn and she didn't she didn't even win
but then would she be discovered if you
weren't on there like that was
it used to be such a big platform but
she didn't win though so i'm trying to
understand like
because because if you get in the top
ten then you go on a tour the top ten go
on a tour together
so there's all the other things in the
top 10 they go on their own tour
together
because obviously there's millions and
millions of people watching they're
selling out
how long are they in this country it's
years and they own a lot of your [ __ ]
so carrie's still under it no she's out
oh she was like season
three or something oh good okay first
ones yeah like kelly clarkson was like
she was like three or four clarkson was
one two might have been carrie underwood
i don't know oh i don't know i don't
know her she was that long ago
yeah it's been a hot minute when the
fantasia win
did fantasia win yeah she won she won so
that but i mean
it sounds like this contract can like
[ __ ] you yeah it's tough though right
because the american i was like well no
one know who you are if it wasn't for us
yeah that's true that's fair that's fair
but still though that's a master it's
tough right yeah what are you doing they
said ultimate fighters kind of saying oh
yeah
they had me i was fighting gonzaga like
top
ten guy gonzaga cro cop nogara for like
base level money yeah but then they're
like well the reason you're getting
these big fights
people know who you are yeah so that's
so like if i was a manager i wouldn't
have a kid going ultimate fighter now
no it's not big anymore so you just get
that shitty contract you're in it for
for a long time oh they don't have
ultimate fighter anymore or are they
what was it on when you did it spike oh
biggest season of
ink master came on so maybe like people
just like like stayed
they said the same way they're like oh
[ __ ] hey that's a fight
you just gonna wear that hat like that
just gonna come in here
looking like school boy
i think the voice gets bothered
you're right i was talking [ __ ] about
shows i don't even [ __ ] watch yeah
man
i don't know what i'm rambling this is
my [ __ ] i know it's like if i want to
win i'll give you that i decided you're
winning but you're right like
like preacher and some guy it depends it
depends yeah i guess
i'm thinking because yeah i'm thinking
of superstars yeah yeah
you're right i'm thinking like
superstars and the voice has
never had a stream but yeah but like
yeah even american idol talk [ __ ] about
like if you want to become a star
you come here you kind of like that's
them throwing jabs and people
if no one's ever done [ __ ] from the
voice also people probably know
more american idol people even if they
didn't win then they would know the
voice
if you really think about it do you
think that boys have auditions like the
prizes
like american 100 percent a lot of them
not this one won't do that audition
stuff
but but they do say american idol is
harder to make okay because there's so
many people dude
i'm telling you and i'm not just saying
the talent level american house season
is nutsos
i don't know who the [ __ ] gentlemen
there's one black guy who's kind of the
favorite this huge
every how long are we pretending to have
diabetes he's so out of shape
but he's such a good singer rupert
rubin's standard 3.0
better than ruben stutter better than
rubenstein
he sings rihanna shine bright like a
diamond and they
dude i was singing rihanna really bro i
love rihanna i love it i love her too
dude she's so [ __ ] talented they said
really
just just just type in american idol
sing bright like a bright like a diamond
2021.
they say rihanna seemed like she got
bronchitis is that true no
i don't i don't know what barbecue rat
that said that she said
what barbecue you were at
right here 2.3 we got the same haircut
are you happy about it and you also look
the same when you took a picture of mike
tyson france and god
[Laughter]
would you we'll
[Laughter]
he's such a heavily favor to win i think
it's gonna [ __ ] up the viewership
you know when like someone's so good
like oh he's gonna win yeah
get ready
okay but everything every time it
performs it's like a home run so you're
like
all right and then they bring on people
after me like all right [ __ ] there's
only one girl who has
the most ridiculous ash version in your
life i sent to the justin my dog
holler at this chick she was built for
justin oh that triggers she has like a
skinny waist yeah
ass is like yeah who was
uh who was the asian dude that popped
off this
but he wasn't good yeah i know who
you're talking about william william
they don't do that anymore damn now it's
all like super sad stories
oh really because that's the people
because they because i think people just
like to watch
you know i like talent talent
climb i guess the talent's nuts like
there's a homeless mom on there and
she's pretty good
yeah it's nuts [ __ ] it's crazy
yeah they'll start you don't did they
make you cry
oh i've cried before yeah he came over
here and said i cried last night oh yeah
oh yeah oh
yeah yeah they do it on purpose i'm like
god damn man and then you want them to
win
is that the homeless one uh her and her
mom were homeless yeah they lived out of
the car
she used the super homeless one all
right and her dad was homeless too
jeez bro i'm not about to yeah oh it's
too much
yeah i like it and when they tell a
story i'm like please be [ __ ] good
please be good
and then they're always no they're
always you're like okay
and then what one uh girl she's like i'm
gonna sing an original i could tell
her confidence is not there she gets on
the piano and katy perry is like hold on
what do you mean because usually when
you're singing original it's a bad idea
okay he's like why he said well like how
did this song come about before you sing
this
should i go well my mom walked out on us
uh like four weeks ago so it's a song i
wrote about her
like this this to my mom and she starts
playing oh it's so good
but she wasn't that talented oh like
don't get me wrong
she was good but that not that
it's hard to judge that though like you
you know it's not though because
talent followed her like this the white
girl with the ridiculous ass came on
next and she can sing like that black
guy oh yeah
oh they're almost the same they're all
the same person yeah it's one
thing that guy do you like that guy what
do you think i didn't think it was
amazing but i thought it was good
wow i'm serious well god damn it
it's not
he's not my favorite there's a kid on
there reminds me a little bit of like
ben harper
he only does acoustic yeah yeah ooh he's
[ __ ] ben harper said what
plays the what's that like i don't know
what's his name what's his name ben
harper no no the other
the guy oh i i don't even know i don't
know names
ben harper plays the guitar like super
crazy right yeah
maybe contestant he has a hat on um
he's a like a head like that he's from
utah he's a guitarist too right not a
hat like that
not a helmet a white guy a white guy
um oh that kid was great i'm the blind
kid
the who a blind so if you got american
top uh you
scroll down chin if you go to uh
american isle top 24 we'll move on from
rick and i after this on that yeah
because people don't watch america like
jesus christ dude i don't even watch it
yeah but i'm intrigued though i know
not her not uh nope not her
there's a lot of young kids on there
it's a lot of girls like some 15 year
olds
this one no no he's really good though i
was like
she's really good
whoa nope is that kid in play nope
he's good though nope
nope nope nope
there's no no 100 is really good
no hold on heel's killing it keep going
he'll have a hat on that bet keep going
yes there he is all right
wyatt pike super talented uh country
you're gonna dig him chin no
white like folk oh folk
[Music]
he's super original he's also ready for
it like he's been performing
gigs on his own all around the country
like driving
so he like has the experience so he's a
beast on stage too like the moment's not
too big for him and he writes all his
own [ __ ] too
this one he didn't write but my girl
thinks katy perry is so pretty do you
cat i think she's pretty i don't think
she's like the most
beautiful woman in the world my girl
does oh really yeah
who do you think is the prettiest girl
in the world like celebrity wise if you
had to choose if hers was katy
perry no who i don't know every girl is
those instagram girls
clearly i mean oh i talked to izzy
you know how we were like oh dizzy left
a comment on her he's like dude she
walked out with me into my fight man
let's take a little break from the
shenanigans because this episode of
fighter and the kids is sponsored by
blue chew
guys it's been one hell of a year
personally i feel like i've aged
30 years over the last 12 months it's
been a beast if you're like me you're
feeling
more your age it's just tough especially
in the sack can't wake my big man up
anymore
so it's time to snap out of it spring is
here it's time to get
sprung with blue chew blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis
but in chewable form at a fraction of
the cost bluetooth tablets help men
achieve harder stronger erections to
combat
all forms of ed bluechu is an online
prescription service so
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations no waiting line at
the pharmacy
ships right to your door discreet little
package you don't have to worry about it
and it's so easy sign up at
bluetooth.com consult one of their
licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
again it's all done online all right
blue chew is made in the u.s of a and
are prepared and shipped direct so it's
cheaper than the pharmacy
so this sounds like something you could
use in the sack in the bedroom visit
bluetooth.com for more details
important safe safety information and i
got a deal for the fire and the kids
listeners try blue chew free
when you use the promo code fighter at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's bluechew.com
fighter to receive your first month free
and i thank bluechu for being part of
the podcast
this episode is also brought to you by
unleashed with dingo and danny a new
podcast fueled by monster energy
these boys get lit this summer
professional skateboarder naija houston
will represent the usa in tokyo for
skateboarding's olympics debut
but for niger the real skateboard
happens in the streets putting out
videos
shredding with your friends being a
thrasher that's what it's really about
plus he keeps a voodoo doll on his
nightstands
as a talesman superstition or secrets to
success
here for yourself by tuning to episode 1
of the podcast as niger breaks down raw
street skating
living the life of the world's most
winning street street skater
hosted by sports personality the dingo
uh you've probably seen him with jason
ellis and professor skateboarder danny
cass
unleashed his alternative sports podcast
you've all been waiting for brought to
you by monster energy
oh i talked to izzy you know how we were
like oh dizzy
left a comment on her he's like dude she
walked out with me into my fight man
remember when he walked out then real
miles and she was dancing
oh i didn't even chill bro i was like
wait oh
[ __ ] i said how could you lose
[Laughter]
a losses how could you lose [ __ ]
hillary i'd risk it all for her how can
you lose doug
i apologize izzy she walked out with the
rece his last fight no
i forget what's right you have your yeah
like dancers yeah yeah i remember that
one
she was one of the dancers and the other
one was batty too oh she's a dancer
yeah well no no she's like no oh i think
she's just famous and walked out not
when he was like
no no no no you know you don't know what
we're talking about huh it was like two
like african nigerian girls
and she's one of the girls that's why i
was a girl we were like
dude how about i bring these two to a
friend i i co-hosted hot boxes mike
tyson with frank silgano
so i bring these two with me this one
falls asleep the entire interview no
you'll fall asleep
how long the entire time it was oh you
you passed out
a little bit no no lewis is taking
pictures of him
he has one if he's sleeping yeah he said
every time you come by and take a
picture
your eyes would pop up i'm like he's
like but i got one he showed me like
he's like who falls asleep with my
tights and francis it was
it was tired yeah and that guy i knew
the guy who was with
uh mike tyson oh yeah yeah you were
talking to that guy he was talking to me
a long time i was like bro this is yeah
yeah i'm looking at y'all none of y'all
look back i'm like can you he made me uh
he was like you want me mike i was like
yeah let's meet mike
i went over there met mike tyson he was
so sedated i'm talking about like you
guys like yo man
what's up okay you're here for the
interview i said no i'm not you're not
i'm not interviewing oh you thought it
was yeah
that makes sense for the interview
now it was a great show yeah i was fun
the show's tough because again it's hot
boxing with mike tyson mike
it's mike tyson's show and they used to
have an
original co-host no no there's
a white guy the original one oh um
he's like a radio guy right yeah and
people fans loved him
and i don't know what happened but for
some reason he was booted from the show
and he was really i also enjoyed the
show more when he was on i got to be
honest
okay um there he is yeah is that him
even britain yeah okay i'm thinking
someone
else i think that's it yeah yeah that's
him
i think so come on let me look at images
real quick okay
uh looks like no that's him that's it
that's what
it so he was the original coach oh this
dude yeah
that guy yeah this guy so he was the
original coast and he was great but
i have listen i my team pro
so malka who produces showtimes content
food truck
also produces hot boxing okay so that's
my connection there
they have nothing to do with the talent
they have nothing to do with it
so he was i guess kicked off or i don't
know what happened i don't know the
background of it i wish i did we should
have him
[ __ ] he's huge he yeah i think he played
in the nfl yeah okay
but he was great i like to show more
when he's the host and then now they're
trying to find
a co-host i don't have the bandwidth i'm
not the guy
yeah yeah so so they try to find a
co-host so
when france was on they called me
thursday morning we're like yo
can you help out mike tyson i love mike
love francis so i was like yeah i'm in
the prom is is
as much as mike you know mike tyson has
hotbox that's his world when it comes to
podcasting that's my you're my you're in
my world now yeah yeah yeah you know
what i'm saying
so it's tough for me not to make the
brendan shop show like you gotta include
my it's mike tyson's show
so that's the i had that anxiety yeah oh
that makes sense yeah
it's a lot of pressure it's a big it was
a big a lot of pressure that's a big one
yeah
it was great it was great i didn't mean
to follow the drop it drops
so it's going to be on both food truck
and below the belt on thursday morning
at 9 00 a.m oh hey
here's first on tyson's youtube on
wednesday okay
okay that's dope though it was dope it
was it was crazy to see
big boys man you know it was just wild
like walking in there
and then i see tyson and then i see the
biggest pit bull
i've ever seen in my entire life and i
go this makes sense yeah
this is that's a big everything is not
supposed to go yeah it had francis
brendan you they said they so i posted a
picture on my
my my page and they said it's a bad
angle it's a bad angle
and again comments are fantastic
oh what did you what did someone they
said looks like mr incredible before you
got to check oh yeah
[Applause]
mary puts on the suit yeah that's they
say go to the picture [ __ ]
is it alex page yeah it's on valley
street you think i was going to post
that look at it
just look how big i mean look at me
standing next to mike tyson
you look like oh my god you look like
that singer for american idol
i know you look like what was maui
like a diamond like a diamond
they took my they they said i was uh
bullying chappelle
because i said oh yeah instagram made it
made him take it down because he said
wait hold on what happened so i post
this picture there's so many comments
and i tagged you pale remember it was
like uh
chappelle didn't want me to post this
because he said he looked fat okay he
does
i was like francis and i we looked at
okay same size
instagram took that post and said cause
they said it was it's harassment
bullying
oh my comments was just lighting
chappelle up oh
and they took it oh they thought you
were bullying
chappelle exactly but i didn't know they
did that but then in the comments
they could post whatever they want no no
it's probably the comments too the
comments too pulling the comments
and they don't know the relationship
each other up meanwhile like
i thought yeah they don't know we're
[ __ ] cause he commented on this i
even commented yeah
you know it's crazy instagram saw that i
thought it was so that's what's so weird
so like
the original comments like the funny
ones aren't they
they're they're a lot because uh yeah
they were they were lighting here
what did i say oh you couldn't make
really some of this time around because
that was the second pose it's just an
angle like you're you've gotten in
better shape but you look
like bro i had to post i'd be like 400
pounds i had to post a different picture
that
so look at this black and white so go to
his page go to his face
bro we were in the car and the way that
look he said i don't know what to do
[Laughter]
oh bro look at the place here what the
[ __ ] an asu 3 university of phoenix
online
segment now where we uh rank people what
oh yeah
like go go to uh find the kid uh
instagram chin
fire guinness round yeah they put on the
story
you're writing them dudes yeah so people
can submit a picture of their friends
their girls
them whoever they want
oh my god that's not even missing your
headshot
pitch yourself or family and give a
little background to the fighter and the
kids shop at gmail.com or you can dm
the fire and the kid instagram oh and
we'll see it there too
if you want to be future on the show
that's the way to do it
they've been rating us do they rate you
do they say all the time oh yeah
they're all the time what do they say to
you though
yeah like you well they said he's
consistent they're like
people
are they being nice to you are people
like john you're good
hey man you come to west virginia you
were 15.
makes sense that's it yeah they say like
the most random like
you're indiana they call it justin a
thailand nine say you got potential
thailand he was like man [ __ ] y'all
just a new zealand 7.
do you have some already some of the
submissions i know you got something
oh dudes already sent it in
let's see look at brandon just making
himself look good
the coolest chapel i didn't make that oh
i have nothing to do with that
that's the way you guys look not like
that anymore
oh yeah i'm cutting my hair all right
this is uh adam del toro
he does a lot of jiu jitsu ventura i
feel like i'm in la
4.5 4.5 oh
he's not a 4.5 oh he looks like that uh
guerrero the box of guerrero old school
boxers i was gonna
he was like marquez doesn't he the boxer
no you ever see marquez yeah
no he's looking like a little more yeah
that's something no absolutely not
well no you ever seen him chin
bring it up no not this dude i'm
thinking of someone else okay yeah
about to say brilliant guerrero the
guerrero the boxer yeah
he's only got in trouble for putting
cement in his wraps
oh he's talking about margarito
margarita
damn solid reference all right
that's what he looks like him man man
yeah he said he's not
he thinks he's a 4.5 you don't think he
is no what do you think he is
i think he's higher than five i give
that guy and to see more of the bombs
you said he's i need him without glasses
bro
he's better looking justin no you could
play my homie bro look at that bone
structure look at the cheeks go to
chicken
justin gotta he got cheeks
he's a west side six side six he's a
east
la seven yeah the west side six yeah
okay what else you got jeff all right
next one uh this one unfortunately no
name no
no like a there's zero description on
them but this could be like a
uh maybe i'll be catfishing yeah i was
about to say
well there's two pictures one of him and
his girl and wife and him dude them eyes
are ten i'll tell you oh
yeah no he's smoking hot yes smoking
blue eyes he has great facial hair yeah
whatever
that boy's at eight that boy's name he's
a heart he's a heart la8
nine point three i give him i give him
8.5 he's an arkansas nine
oh arkansas arkansas 12. no i'd say
arkansas
yeah what's up in arkansas
he's not 10. look at arkansas there's
some baddies in arkansas bro i know and
he's one of them i never see the body
but face wise he's he's solid look at
the body i see him
ufc fan yeah bro got a clean crease
yeah it's so symmetrical everything
wasn't so symmetrical it looks fake you
got that mario like if you use that
filter where you flip the face over it
looks exactly the same
his eyes are gorgeous he's an eight
he's an eight bona fide eight do you
think higher than eight not point three
i get i give him
10 is to each of you okay what's what's
ten to you
huh yeah let's specify what's a ten to
all of you that you can all agree on
who's a ten for that
hit or bradley cooper would be a tenant
they live in los angeles okay yeah okay
those are tens walking the street you're
telling me this
good looking dude you're telling me he's
the equivalent of brad pitt if you put
him
next to side by side of bradley cooper i
guarantee you he'll hold his own
he'll hold his head hold his arm brenda
are you serious no yes
if a squadron girl see both of them
bradley cooper has a name you're out of
your mind are you
go to the other no to the other one let
me just see
i think it looks better in the first
picture yeah personally but this is more
real
the angle of this picture is just a
little weird we know how he looks
we know about angle now you know i look
300 pounds
yes depending on the
angle okay
you know that man but working on look at
that gorgeous now compare him
stop by oh boy am i crazy here no
i think you're pretty spot on it's not
that the other guy isn't good oh also
bradley's six
four bro [ __ ] bona fide dime this guy
can be six
three wait bradley cooper six four yeah
he's big really tall man
i had no idea i didn't know you were six
four five six i thought it was like five
four
okay what five four yeah you know
somebody's some of these actors are like
you gotta be totally tall you gotta
six foot no he's not he's not six foot
no he's not i've seen him in person not
six foot okay
mark wahlberg short this one name
anybody yeah name another name
besides the rock who's big yeah i feel
like most actors are fairly short
and i see them on the carpet i feel like
you're on a taller spectrum of yeah
i've never seen like just tall actors no
they're not big
is chris hemsworth that's all he's tall
he's big he's kind of
excited he's six four oh yeah so he's
like even the guy just six four what's
the guy who plays the hulk he's tall
michael ruffalo mark ruffalo yes mark
ruffalo's five
eight no i seen him in real life he's
five eight he's not tall he's he's tall
to me no he's not tall
bro he was looking at that he's five
eight and that's off wikipedia so he's
really five
seven five six are you serious robert
downey jr five nine
no one's huge yeah no one yet no one saw
him in real life maybe i still some
no you don't know what you're talking
about oh keep going
all right this one you know the girl you
know who's super short
the dude who plays jon snow kate
harrington
he's like five five five six oh he's
going to throws yeah he looks very short
then
oh this is cass 24 year old 24 years old
from new york half asian half white
and her mirror is dirty is that the only
pink we got
i think there's another one okay tennis
her instagram
yeah i know just those two pics
we get the rate girls as well yeah
they're submitting
dudes no that's what i thought the show
was oh i know she's cute
she's cute she's cute no i wish i saw
him more though i wish i saw more though
and in this picture she hides her face
the first photo has a filter on it you
can tell she's cute but then
i need them to send like a regular photo
we can go through any pics we want
yeah instagram are they ready they
better be ready for that
instagram handles um i give her seven
yeah she looks like la7 based off of
this i think she could be prettier if i
saw a regular photo i just need to see
more because it seems like a snapchat we
don't know if she has a gap we don't
know any of that
so la7 is kind of high yeah
yeah you the la 7's high i agree it's
high la is hot you gave yourself a la-6
yeah you see i'm saying you know l.a
y'all go to zoo culture all the time bro
you're gonna give that guy
a [ __ ] night and then this girl you
think a seven is dude
you guys are out of your [ __ ] mind we
don't have a segment
are you stepping
you're saying we don't know if we should
have a gap let's assume that she has
all her appendages and not a gap
yeah i'm going over what i see right now
you don't give that a seven i mean bit
of a forehead
but still a seven you know
if you're gonna sign up for this spot
there's gonna be some shots listen
listen the two pictures is the reason
why i will not give thank you we don't
have enough information the other guy
only had two picks and one was a shitty
pick can you give him a nine that was
not a shitty pig
you said it was a shitty piss no then he
said well cause he didn't you thank you
that yeah so you said it was a shitty
pant yes
and you said you want to judge me based
off a shitty pic i went you said sure
he said the angle no i said the angle
you said that was bad
no look at her pick is her covering her
face taking a selfie in the mirror
i can't see anything you can't see
anything you can see her face and that
when you see the body in the other one
it's a filter on the first pit
it's a filter filter there is a filter b
that's a filter
and you didn't even hear my rating
what's your already i know what it is
6.5 that's not bad yeah that's fair
that's true
that's not bad yeah
right now based off your evaluation of
the first one
you're like that's a bad picture it's
about an angle i'm like well this one
she's good
like the other one we can't even see
it's a bad picture but listen that was
the only one we were fair with the first
guy
east la7 uh seven um
picture i gave him a nine point three
that guy yeah
the first guy no the second guy gave me
the second yeah the second guy yeah i'm
sorry yeah second guy
this guy right that guy you gave 9.3
yeah i feel like i can tell everyone's
biases already i feel like brendan and i
are more forgiving
for girls and you guys more forgiving
for guys that's what it is like no i
feel like i'm a little higher i'll tell
you right now i'll be harsher on the
dudes they can handle a little pete
yeah girls come out i was saying yes 645
is not bad but i'm saying
you're going to give her lower than i
was like no no
we almost should write them down ahead
of time because cat
she says seven and she can't give
herself a six i was like ain't no way
i said six or seven cat's not a
narcissist she's doesn't give herself a
nine no
no you can't have her in her she's
[ __ ] crazy i know right yeah
i got 10. chappelle call yourself late
you want me
i said brad pitt or bradley
but i'm saying the girl i just needed
more information i was going to go to
the next one
six or seven is fair okay overall score
six and a half okay but we need more
okay this is marcus 25 euro 25 years old
from rhode island
single i don't know i know right people
say i kind of like a skinny hold on let
me let me finish
it people say i get like a skinny
version of big brown himself
i feel like i'm a northeast how do i
think
i would handle the midwest and cali at
the underscore marcus suggs on instagram
for more pictures to roast
or gas up oh that's him okay okay you
wanna
so oh we gotta write our rating now yes
oh this is about to be fun okay write
your ratings down and then we will
he looks like a skinny andrew scholes
yeah that's a way better you don't look
like yeah
like luigi from super mario he does look
like luigi
okay la right l.a stanford we're just
strictly la's dude come on
who is that guy he's with right there i
know that guy
uh should i do my hair blonde i don't
know should i dye my hair blonde again
a comment said hell no
[Laughter]
hell no you look like uh that guy from
the stan eminem video
come on
flipping the camera off there it is
right there with the glasses yeah let's
analyze that one
well you look like a biker that never
made it
super thin i don't like how he got his
thumbs when you flip people off
yeah it's like the weird weird one yeah
you got to put you got to put them in
thank you come on put them in if you got
weird thumbs put them in put them in
put them in okay i got it what do you
give them let's go with a
female's perspective i would give him an
la5
he has big dick energy i feel like he
does have big dick
turtle dactyl hanging between them he
has that p davidson
like awkward i'm gonna give him a four
or five wait we gotta wait hold on you
gotta say you gotta write it down you
gotta write it down hold your hand if
you're a four odds are you have a big
dick okay so i gave him i gave him all
right chappelle hold yours up i'll get
you
i gave him a four i gave him a four two
la four left four la four okay
yeah yeah four okay marcus
that's a la-4 though dude so it's la-4
good in long island you were seven
yeah north northeast you're killing like
this all you want you're killing me we
gave our friend justin the three
yeah yeah i just want to keep throwing
that out there
remember that he's a bonafide three yeah
remember that when you hear this sucks
all right who else we have uh this is
jim petty fresno california local
comedian
let's take a look what else did he say
thank you give me some more information
just don't skin by him
you know so thick very much so single
depends what day of the week it is
current rating fresno 10
firing kid rating question mark a little
mask off mask on
oh okay that's mask off
there's mask on so not much to go with
here
i think we're all on the same path yep
go ahead you ready yeah i give him a
three i got him oh i gave him a three
point five that's fine
that's fine i'll see you at three i gave
him a three
okay i don't know there's something
about like him looking at that beer can
and then the next one he'll look at the
camera that like doesn't sit right with
me
i don't know what it is it's like he's
hiding himself he's hiding something i
can't i can feel it i just don't know
and that little smurf that snoop dogg
hat is though i would love to see an
actual 10 submit a picture
yeah someone there's a 10 somewhere out
there
we've had a lot of three fours fives and
six yeah that's it
yeah i give him a heart is that it we
got one more all right um
did you get mine here you go you want to
read this i'm a 44 year old colombian
don
diego living in the sixth toronto
father two awesome kids in their 20s
super fan of the pod
do amazing job always look forward to
the next episode happy easter and keep
it thick but aim for that ripped city
all right here we go oh and he's a papa
44 year old 44 years old dude but that
picture looks pretty old too
that's only one one picture
you know you know 44 year olds don't
know how to take pictures right there's
a twin towers behind them
no it's that building drake is sitting
on yeah on the cover view
what are they called what are you
calling it the needle the tower
what's his name don don diego yeah
i'm giving if i'm assuming this is what
he looks like currently i'm giving him a
nine
for whoa what father of two
two forty four what did you get oh
that's trouble with the eight
43. i'm almost there and look at him
i know father of two and you got a four
he's 20 year olds yeah he's 20 year olds
running through this actually he's got
20 year olds yeah he's changing
20 year olds oh we got a factor today
okay cool i got it all right i'm good
now all right good
all right i gave him eight i gave him
eight that's five
what'd you give him nine oh so oh yeah
you already said it yeah
for a dad again 8.5 yeah
that's a deal he's like built too now
time out we could use his instagram but
yeah cause i see they didn't know okay
yeah now send in your instagram handles
please
yeah please yeah helps us out make sure
you're counting private
i know that's another thing that
irritates me they'll send
so then you would have to go through
your uh the photos that they gave you
like those are like their own yeah
another thing is you gotta send more
than one pick he's 44.
have at least one photo like you're
looking at the camera just like
you and your face not hiding really if
you send us your instagram we can figure
it out
and just even at that age he had some
kids man yeah you know that's true i get
it
dang only one girl sent in i don't know
that's an audience
it shocked me that's why i was like
we're writing girls too i didn't know
we had we'll get more i'm sure we mean
no one talked about it earlier
yeah so just people just sent them in
they just sent to me that's jay's like
bringing a bunch of people
asking to rank them i'm like all right
that's funny that's so
funny ranked this is just out of nowhere
yeah
well we started ranking each other but
who does that yeah
i don't think any friend group i don't
know too many friend groups that rate
each other
it's the first it's the first time i've
ever been raided by some homies of mine
and i didn't like it yeah well you're
not having fun
that was all brilliant oh yeah you gave
me i don't know how to start exactly
right you you party who said his
personality again
that's the nicest way to call someone
ugly
i get a lot of conversation that
personality
people keep saying that to me
personality though that personality
though
what makes a [ __ ] personality too
it's personality is more important than
the looks
[Music]
you're trying to make me feel because
well you wouldn't be here
if your personality was a one it'd be a
problem you'd be like flavor flav
no that's the one no he's not a one no
he's you ever watched flavor love
it's so good that [ __ ] was so that you
give him a one yeah because
for bro he put those girls through a
ringer
what do you mean oh they signed up for
it though i don't know yeah that's a
challenge
okay hold on timer the show was for them
to bungee cord
i never forget the episode where they
had to like glide across yeah
i thought he was like the producers go
hey guys
these [ __ ] are zip-lining and he's
like oh okay i don't know what that is
like well they're gonna be on court and
then you judge him
he has nothing to do there's no way he's
not riding that show hey could you have
been on one of those shows
yeah as like a contestant yeah like i
wonder
i want to be a new yorker yeah i want to
be oh
new york was good you're too young yeah
i was too young what about you remember
uh
uh the real chance of love or something
yeah
i wanted to do that one damn but you
didn't make it i didn't make it it'd be
funny if he was a contestant on a that
would be great i'd love to have you i'll
i'd watch it
i watch it every time every night every
night every night robbie doing that's
homies
yeah just watching you could you do
could you do the picking
actually you'd be yeah you could do that
okay i could do the picking was hot
wings good looking yeah she was bad look
at her
she had she was on the tv show too uh
the lebron james show they called
her hot wings because she uh worked at
hooters right yeah
like she looked awful in that picture
but she was bad that's her right now
uh right now now she got like she
covered up a tattoo she just did a naked
scene
on uh on a survivor's remorse what's
that
it's a tv show on uh stars uh lebron
james it's a scripted show
yes it's a screening scripty show look
at her this is her britney hall
that's a real she's gorgeous yeah she's
bad yeah she's super pretty
all up in the yogurt oh she goes she go
the other way
yeah where oh oh she's lesbian now
oh well you ain't winning that show yeah
i was
she is tatted up yeah she's a bad guy
she's
bad
yeah gorgeous yeah she's playing a
different game though
do you remember that show tila tequila
when she had half girls half guys
yeah and that came on empty i saw her at
the airport she had
the biggest head you've ever seen really
she had your body chin's head
it's not a good combo that's a goddamn
bobble head dude
speaking of uh my friend sent me a video
of her how she is today
you guys are quite racist i mean the way
she looks i have it right here dude
the way she looks and she's racist yeah
she's right she thinks she's like a nazi
what yeah
yeah she thinks she's like a asian nazi
yeah i'm thinking she's vietnamese
she's vietnamese guys she's vietnamese
yeah okay she walks around saying that
she's aryan as [ __ ]
she's doing that that's not like you
know no no it's a bummer because she's
just kidding keep watching
okay she's a porno keep watching shawn
marion keep watching the question is
this and bam
oh listen there's some asians in this
world where
they don't age and then there's other
ones that when they age
daddy i think there's more than aging
this is just i don't think so she's like
just gonna be doing stuff
yeah what's that forehead do though baby
you're right that's a big one
that's a good girlfriend so from that
yeah
dang maybe that's why she had the bangs
to hide oh yeah
how big that oh that's exactly what's
going on where are they now
oh mental disorder rehab turn to
religion yeah now she's talking about
aryan nation and [ __ ] like that yeah
where's my eyebrows i know it's nothing
it's a hot mess
wow it's insane she does look like a
fish
that's crazy man maybe that's a bad
angle we know what bad angle is
right well that's but to you but damn
wonder what she does now
they use this thumbnail which freaked me
out oh
that has to be fun that's just
there's like a nose surgery though
that's why there's tape
[ __ ] oh she had no searching
nothing wrong with her nose i think it
was interesting
yeah damn i did not yeah that show used
to be little empty girls and guys
and she came because tequila she came up
but she came off what show she was on
one show
what was she on the show she was on yeah
that's how they found that's how they
found her
love no i don't think it was so your
love that was a different girl that
asian girl was named oyster or something
most popular person on my space i
remember that i think that's it then no
oh not another show i think she was just
popping from myspace yeah because i
just remember tila tequila uh i say what
show was to
tequila because i remember she was on
one show i remember watching that
because she had a show on mtv right
yeah the dating show did you go to imdb
no that yeah no actually i think she was
just a myspace uh yeah i really do too
really yeah
i think she's just popping on myspace
we'll just go to yeah history her first
show was what
i remember on uh i now pronounce you
larry and uh
[ __ ] larry that's such a good movie
great movie yeah
i do remember she was just a huge social
media presence that's right that's what
i remember
yeah my space is she still doing report
did she
14 that says back door and squirting
yeah yeah she did some porn
yeah i know her sex tape oh so did that
one uh which no
that was sweet 16 or not sweet 16.
team mom teamwork what the hell is this
uh uh
abrams yeah fair abrams she did a porno
yeah
yeah yep i've seen her she stopped
kicked her off the show because of it
she wouldn't stop was it that or was it
i heard she was just difficult to work
with no she was definitely difficult but
yeah they were like hey if you're gonna
keep doing porn
then you can't be on the show she's like
i'm gonna stop doing it yeah and then
they had a conversation like hey we hear
you're still doing like this only fan
[ __ ] doing
porn she's like yeah that's what i want
to do like right we can't be on the show
she's alright i'm done
oh wow i i saw one uh i know you did i
saw one that's awesome
which one you're doing yeah
she was at the comedy store a ton she
was yeah i've never seen her
i've never seen anything what's she
doing there watching comedy
oh she was just like oh just watching i
know i think there was a at one point
she wanted to start stand up
oh we we have a lot of porn stars that
try to div
and dab i've never met one except for
her you know which one i'm talking about
yeah
which one uh sylvia sylvia sage yeah
porno star what's her name again sylvia
sylvia i've never seen i've never seen
her set and also there's another girl
uh as well they come but they come to
these open mics
and stuff yeah she
she's pretty she got two different
she wanted people with two different
colored eyes that's cool
oh she was recently in an only fans
documentary that came out on hulu they
got adopted was any good yeah
rollins was on where nikki glazer was on
there
yeah they were they were the comedians
kind of talking about china
she wasn't like donald rawlings was one
of the first non-porno people on youtube
yeah he had a podcast
on fans they paid him to start an
accountant only fans so it wasn't porn
it's just material
oh [ __ ] i didn't know but we think it's
because
it's probably transitioning to like
where like because everything so many
people there's so many people on there
that just don't
do porn they just there's a lot of
fitness people on there now selling like
fitness programs
yeah it makes sense yeah it's a good
spot to go
yeah yeah oh you can make your money you
know
cat do you feel like you have to get
more creative with your only fans or
after a while yeah because there's only
so many things
you can do and i feel like also because
there are certain people who will post
like x amount of times during a week uh
where
as other people will post like whenever
they feel like so maybe like once a
month once
a month those are more like um
those are like really popular like
instagram girls who are trying to make
like passive income so they'll post like
once or twice a month straight up
i felt that you know angry boys like
really
put a little there's a little effort
into it
put your clothes on like some people
will have like a schedule like i work
monday yes once a week once a week once
a week some people will post like once
every single day
yeah i'm down for that stuff like that
but some people will come in and post
like once everybody how often do you
post
twice a day and then once all the time
yep oh then you post the thirst strap
one yeah who comes up does stevie help
with the ideas how's it how's it
happening
i'm not really stevie's just kind of
like living his life in the background
and if i'm recording something of my
feet i have to put on mute if he's
talking
so it's just like a video of like the
soles of my feet
and then like he's walking around
talking to me and i'm looking forward to
your feet
yeah it's like five minutes of nothing
but the soles of my feet wow
damn and that's a pay-per-view it's so
interesting yeah yeah so interesting but
you have to be stevie's trying to get
his big dick in the pig
stop kicking it out of the way
okay
uh i found out because girls like mia
khalifa who are on only fans
once or twice a month she'll do a trip
somewhere else take a bunch of photos
and then post
and the uh when we were in miami i
realized that i was making more money
while i was there
doing the exact same thing that i was
doing here in l.a just because people
are
more inclined to want to see stuff if
i'm not
in my normal environment so i can see
why girls will travel a lot to take
photos so you're gonna start taking a
lot more trips
i mean if it makes sense yeah i don't
see why not it sounds like it is
yeah it sounds and it's attacks right
off yeah what does cat feet look like in
texas
in hawaii
some stubs barbecue and [ __ ] douse at
him
that is weird but i i mean there's a
market for it though
it's almost like a feet block at that
point yeah are you in the feet
i'm i'm not into him but i don't i i
don't
it's not my thing i'm not going to jack
off someone's foot
yeah you're not going to look i'm not
sexually attacked
you're not going to get a boner from
feet no i'm not going to subscribe to
cat [ __ ]
for your feet yeah feet no i need more
which sounds like you're doing it
kind of no nudity but yes yeah you're in
the feet
congratulations you're in the feet you
look like you'd be initially
that stands right there justin seems
like the type of guy to be into 100
percent
oh he's a [ __ ] guy he is a foot guy
[Music]
yeah and he how do you guys know that i
say it's a story i'll give a [ __ ] he'll
watch look [ __ ] it so he goes he was
like yo
he had this girl called t.s right and
you know what that
she's a asian girl and i was like i
thought all along i was like bro why are
you calling ts he called a toe sucker so
what he did
she sucks she exactly so he'll go
he's like ts coming over i got to hurry
up his shower okay
yeah exactly so he'll like bro
that's her thing though you know was she
hot used to be a video
that big toe
if that's what she's into did you just
see justin's feet
like i've never heard of a girl
he's talking like he's a portal he's off
there you there you go there you go
put it there you go there you go there
you go girl
i've never heard of a girl being in
defeat though i don't know some girl
somebody i've heard
yeah you've heard of it i've only known
like known as to be like a dude
to girls i think it's more of a girl
female fetish thing right
as far as sucking on sucking on them i
don't know
no absolutely not i know right i don't
like feet
i really don't like feet i don't give a
[ __ ] if my girl was super in the toes i
don't
know yeah suck on your toes don't give a
[ __ ] you suck on her toes you won't let
her suck on yours
i don't enjoy it i'm not so ticklish i
don't think i could yeah i could not
enjoy that
what happens if you suck on a ticklish
person's feet like they get kicked
like you have to not be ticklish there
to get your toast yeah i couldn't do it
i literally can do it get get off my
feet if your girl was like hey i'm
really into
i'm really into your big tub i'm like
you should have said this [ __ ] earlier
hey we've been together for a minute
would you let your girl suck on your
feet nope
no you let your girl suck on your feet i
mean she wants to yeah
that was like her thing i'm like give me
those toes
stuck on your feet i was sucking my
girl's feet you would know yeah
if i would do it yeah yeah yeah she
wanted it but it's it's me oh yeah
no no yeah cause you don't like being
touched right i don't like being touched
there we go
that's a problem yes jen you're you're a
girl sucking your toes
she no she hasn't but i mean if she
wanted to i'll let her do it yeah y'all
smash regular
no not regular as much as we can though
43.
nipple clamps it's handcuffs it's once a
month daddy
sometimes longer than that i know a 43
year old man
wait what i want to hop chin's busy man
do you guys mind sharing how many times
do you guys do it yeah i don't care i go
for it
every time we go rounds yeah every
single day [ __ ] dude
every day i mean every time we see each
other yeah pretty much oh yeah you don't
see yourself
today how's she not pregnant bc
you know y'all go right is that weird
how old are you
i'm 34. how old is she uh
she'll be 32. oh okay he has been the
other two years
uh it'll be three in september oh that's
good
you guys have a healthy sex life yeah
yeah oh and that's great
that's like that's my first relationship
but you don't yeah that's that's
a big you don't live together you don't
live together so it's different okay
yeah a lot of that's good either
yeah yeah so that's why i thought you
and your girl lived here oh wow
she remember she's helping take care of
kids in orange county oh that's right
that's right that's right remember that
all right i thought you guys moved in
together no oh wow
yeah you get down a lot yeah 100 i hate
the way he's at i know i do
i don't think you do he's i don't know
he doesn't why your answer's so smooth
yeah of course we do
it's my first time wearing a hat on the
show you and stevie have been together
how long
um since august how long is that so
that's pretty new too you guys are
pumping like rabbits yeah pretty often
more i would say like
three to four times a week not every
single day but like pretty often that
sounds like kind of normal
yeah for like a normal relationship for
an actual relationship people live
together yeah yeah i feel like when you
live apart
you [ __ ] more often for sure yeah
because more excited about it
oh we're on each other's nerves oh god i
gotta go dude when you got kids all day
yeah oh yeah
one of them can wait my girl's bad
goddamn
yeah there's an earthquake last night
yeah
yeah oh man you felt it oh yeah oh
it shook my shoes down i didn't feel i
didn't feel i've i heard rattling but i
just thought
i was in a dr i was dreaming so i didn't
think i didn't feel i didn't feel like a
shake
damn you look like run dmt right now
fat
like the oldest school rapper man
i think you can rock a bucket hat but
not that bucket hat
no like a hello cool j one i never wear
hats can't go ever never wear hats
never wear hats because i feel like i
look crazy in heaven now you look cool
though you look fine
you know i feel like i just look like a
[ __ ] psycho hello
someone wants to send me a hat i'll
[ __ ] wear it but yeah buy one of
these
you ever wore these uh i actually
actually used to have like a golfer
kangal had god father no yeah
that's that's i love one of those uh
golfer is it a golfer hat that's
newsboy hat thingy right what do you
call those like i feel like that's the
hassle you used to play
the newspaper yeah it's called something
else
i think i actually like this hat malik
huh yeah tangle
there it is candles i've said kangal
seven it's a brand but but
the actual style the main brand yeah
yeah that's pizza blenders
paper tissue blinders yeah that's what
that is yeah
i'll rock your head you had a blade you
could rock that i want i want one that
says oasis on it though
yeah we don't have that they probably
you should rock this one chapel
which one the wider ones should old
school old school
huh i used to have one like the one on
the right this one
so i used to have that i used to wear
these biker boots all the time and i had
this wallet change
microphone yeah that's right that's when
i was really drinking
really yeah i used to go to these these
little dive bars and i'd be that dude
in the band t-shirt biker boots
i don't know who the [ __ ] i was i don't
know either i have a leather jacket too
that's like really a lost soul though
drinking myself
who's blade that's what you're gonna see
two days
bro wesley snipes
when are you doing it
okay so ari uh manus posted this
last night apparently snl uh the snl
episode that aired this past weekend
had uh this actor on it and they did a
salt bay
uh sketch and this was aired on april
3rd 2021 in
i believe it was june of 2020 ari
and his friend actually wrote a sketch
that they submitted to snl
for the writers exactly
and uh i guess they didn't get picked up
and
he his friend who wrote it stole his
idea put it
on his instagram who got shot
let me see it jin
july 9th 2020.
he said it twice
okay yeah i heard he's actually here
tonight
i wonder if he'll be here tonight
like he didn't already manage to kind of
look like
oh my god
oh my turn i guess oh
[Music]
that's the girl working at the hollywood
emperor drop it
down my throat i guess what drop it down
my throat
again they literally saw everything here
[Music]
definitely oh it's definitely actually a
sketch
i guess what happens though is like if
you
like you basically give them i don't
know i don't know there's some
something like that do they say that if
you submit we can use the idea and not
pay for it
there's no way ari's not the first
person this has happened to no i know
dude this is that's the problem yeah but
they're stealing ideas
and also when when um oh what's his name
goat boy what's his name goat boy
he's famous as [ __ ] come on man from
tonight live
uh oh god come on oh jim burke yeah
actually
was on rogan he's saying how they would
steal his ideas so he would go into this
he's a writer
no he's a performer so go boy
so he would go on the show and the way
saturday night live works they sit
around the table and
he would go i have this idea and it
would pitch it and then the writer's
like nah we don't like that one
then months later the ride like oh i got
this idea and jim's like bro
that's the idea i pitched [ __ ] two
months ago like nah i don't know what
you're talking about
he would take it as his idea so jim was
saying he was sick of them stealing
ideas
and then he said he had an idea and
because you know there's certain seasons
when it's like
certain weeks when it's bigger and he'd
say i'd hold all my good stuff for then
so he said he pitched one was like i'm
gonna wait to pitch that
yeah and then someone stole his idea and
pitched it during the peak weeks
so i guess they're known for it lame
dude that's the camera
but they've always has problems like
when uh riders from nbc abc
cbs would come to the comedy store and
they see a comic do a bit or
something they'd write the idea down and
then go back to their networks might go
i came up with an idea for a show and be
a bit from a comic
oh wow it happens all the time producers
too yeah producers and music yeah like
they'll send beats
now we don't want that talking about the
cardi b up song well look at amy schumer
right like a bunch of her staff writers
stole a bunch of ideas then
then i don't know what happened who
knows if she stole or not but her staff
definitely did
yeah yeah like well it's similar
thinking it's like i don't know dude
there's just some things that are just
not like that one's pretty bad that was
pretty yeah that was pretty
stole my man stuff man nothing's gonna
happen
that's what i'm saying yeah nothing they
probably have something to find that's
what i'm saying they're saying if you
submit you like it yeah
which is weird yeah yeah it's like why
don't you just take the person on
so the other day dmx was uh
uh put into a hospital and i believe he
was on life support for a while
because he actually had a drug overdose
he was like
52 he's 50 yeah he's an older man i'll
be 54 doing heroin daddy
he was taken off of life support because
he was able to breathe on his own
yeah but he's currently in a vegetative
state and a lot of
people uh actually went outside of the
hotel he's staying at and they start
playing his music just showing support
and love
that's terrible man oh they haven't been
a hotel room it's any day now
no he's not in a hotel he's in a
hospital oh bro you oh dude
no he said they stood out outside the
house
no hospital they're outside a hospital
there he's
he's in vegetative state so he can't
take his own vegetable state and put him
in a hotel
yeah he's i thought she said something
about a hotel that's uh
hospital he's gonna be in there for a
while yeah it's any day now right
because vegetative state is like he's a
vegetable yeah
yeah it i think it's technically he is
like there's no brain activity is that
right yeah if he's on live support
vegetative state yeah that means
on it's currently a vegetative state
yeah that ain't good so they're actually
having a probably breathing machine yeah
that means and his lawyer got
i got so happy when his lawyer came out
and said oh he's doing great
and then the lawyer was like oh i got
misinformed
yeah there were a couple different
things that came out that day that made
it weird some people were like oh he's
fine he's gonna make a full recovery and
then
there were other reports saying he's
actually still in critical condition
we're still praying for him
if it's vegetative state it doesn't look
good but who said vegetative state
though
according to his manager yeah that's
terrible
um that sucks man 54 doing
what 50 50. i don't think they told
anyone oh what type of drugs he took
but oh they haven't said anything i
couldn't find it he used to do crack
but it's he had a creative story like he
you know coming from a group home his
mom and no dad like that
didn't have a mom like his story is
reason why okay
how he made it out to become a rapper
it's crazy
so you know first sound man he still
shouldn't be doing drugs at 50 though
i mean that's all he knew that's a
bummer
he go that's how he helps a lot of
musicians like they need to
be out of sight yeah i get it yeah and
he just never knew had that person to
just
sit him down okay in other news uh
paul pierce he is a former nba player i
believe he played for the celtics
he was on instagram live and this is one
of those cases where like older heads
not knowing how to use
social media properly he had a bunch of
strippers in his home with all of his
boys and he was
instagram living everything and so he
was trending
read the comments uh he wasn't really in
trouble just we were like
whose father is this like get him off of
instagram live well is he what can we
get volume chips is there a music in
this
please please is he trying to flex your
girl stop [ __ ] yeah
yeah what you're doing somebody gonna
throw a point [ __ ]
someone saying you married l.a come
through
sit down if you're in l.a monica come
through you know
[Applause]
do you have kids
oh no he knew he was on live he just
doesn't i don't think he
realizes like what what social media
really is
like how many people are actually seeing
it damn i think uh someone also brought
up he
uh tweeted something once and he didn't
know exactly what an emoji is
so instead of putting the emoji in the
tweet he got a picture of the emoji and
put it in
so it's just like he's older he doesn't
really know
yeah he has a bunch of uh video clips
going around the internet right now
because i guess this live
lasted for a while oh really [ __ ]
you got that i mean he's not even
enjoying the stripper he's just [ __ ]
shooting this getting but he's getting a
massage
all right wow okay
and cher is currently under fire because
i believe it was a tweet that she put
out saying that she was really
saddened by the george floyd stuff and
she felt like if she was there she could
have stopped it
and people are like why are you saying
this people are
coming after her for being insensitive
because i thought some people wouldn't
understand and believe that
entertainment could have an honest
emotion about human beings suffering
dying even if it's only shown on tv
you don't know what i've done who i am
or what i believe i can i have
and will help yeah i mean what's the
point of that tweet though man
also you're not gonna help you know
there was a uh actual
emt that white girl in the back with the
phone out
she's actual emt that knows uh cpr the
girl with the headband on yeah she
testified she was like hey
he's dying let me help him and recover
him and the cops are like then back the
[ __ ]
up she's like no i can literally save
his life come see her right now
before the ambulance anyone comes
they're like back the [ __ ] up they
wouldn't let anybody get close to help
so share you think your 80 year old ass
is going to get in there and help
also he he died like you tweeting that
does nothing it didn't
yeah it does nothing damn i said have
you been watching the trial
yeah that guy's [ __ ] yeah
and rightfully so yeah all right
all right [ __ ] because they've been they
even had the head of the
police force be like well they were
saying like
the how they subdued him you know and
like held him down
that makes sense but to sit on his neck
for nine minutes makes no sense no sir
so
once you subdue them they stop fighting
you can back off however you know they
control
his feet his arms and his neck and
they're taught that
that to do that would put the knee on
their neck they actually teach that
but not for nine minutes that's just a
bad dude
you watch the video it's infuriating
yeah it just makes you mad this is sad
man
the bummer is the the the body camera
that showed where he's like man i don't
want no prob like he's like i don't want
no problem
exactly he's like leave me alone man and
then you know the reason all this
happened is he was
he had counterfeit money he was trying
to pay for so the kid who
ran the store this young kid you can see
him when the cops come he's like this
like oh
[ __ ] i wish i didn't call the cops but
he didn't know though
no he didn't yeah there's no way for him
yeah it's horrible he
hit him scream for his mom dude it's
terrible his mom passed
but also him keeps saying i can't
breathe dude get off me i can't breathe
it's like what are you doing yeah
and uh dude what was the case what was
the guy who said i can't breathe with
those new york uh erica
this one's even worse because you're
talking about nine minutes and there's
several people around trying to help
they wouldn't allow them access to help
back the [ __ ] up yeah and then for them
to say
well he was on drugs and that's the
reason why i died i don't give a [ __ ]
he had all that [ __ ] in his system he
had drugs in his system was a drug
addict or whatever
that he would still be alive if he never
encountered you guys so i don't get what
the prosecution what defense they're
gonna have
yeah well yeah drugs in the system he's
a bad guy that's nothing to do with this
because if he never encountered you he
would be alive
so you killed him yeah and didn't he uh
meet that guy
uh derek uh chauvin yeah
prior so there was some ego thing though
he didn't like him or something
yeah you know staff they're filming all
the smoke around they're stacked it was
super cool
yeah they look identical yeah yeah they
look like twins dude
yeah stack would send them shoes and
gear and [ __ ]
it's terrible man he went on a tour uh
stack
yeah for georgia yeah still going on
it's terrible i want to see that cop's
[ __ ] yeah there's no way he gets up
dude if he were i know if he were to get
off it's over
you think we have problems now it's over
listen
derek you gotta take one for the team
you gotta go away you gotta i don't give
a [ __ ] if you think you're guilty or not
you gotta go away dude
you gotta go away for a long
all time all right i think those watts
rights were bad
bro oh he gets off yeah
ain't nowhere gonna be safe but i
guarantee he's not gonna get on that
there's no way
there's no way you can watch that like
take it like they're gonna say oh drugs
this i don't give a [ __ ] any of that you
watch that
you have multiple cops being like yeah
that's too long man everyone's like
that's too much
even the police they interviewed the
police chief black guy i forgot his name
this morning he was just like yeah
it's entirely tumult he's trained
there's a certain way they train
and he just over excessive he's like bro
you could have got up and
doing it to brenda's point it's nuts i
don't think he gets off but damn
he's not gonna get off don't put that
energy out and then he's not gonna get
off and then think about this when he's
in prison
he's going to be in [ __ ] solitary
confinement you can't put him out in the
yard
oh no no and here's the other thing he's
going to go to prison
but guarant bet my last dog goes to
prison once he's in there i would also
about a ton of money they get a hold of
him
there's no way he stays alive long the
cop no way
they'll get to him they find a way to
get to everybody
think about whitey bulger he was in
[ __ ] top flight
you're talking about the top prisons in
all the [ __ ] land
they transferred him and in the transfer
they got to him
they figure it out man that's tough
the thing about the pain and chaos he's
caused every american
not just african-americans every
american well because
after that all white people aren't like
we don't [ __ ] with him man
that's not we don't he doesn't vouch for
us not everyone's like him
well that led during covet to all the
protests and the riots and you know it's
the perfect storm
people are locked down they're mad
already at the con the the conditions
and then we see
that yeah and then just everything
boiled over the top we were in houston
we in the day that it happened and we
just
there were snipers on top of the [ __ ]
roofs downtown denver dude
it was nuts you see that video because
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
because your ego your it's not yeah it
rages yeah
all right uh next one
kevin durant was fine fifty thousand
dollars for this but the back and forth
a very good friend mike rapport [ __ ]
up i don't vouch for him on this
so it's like think about our group text
imagine if you posted that
all the jokes we make all the [ __ ]
like the way we talk to each other
we're friends it's the way we
communicate but it would look like it
would look like
that's not for the public yeah so if
that gets out i would do
i'd lose all my sponsors yeah katie same
thing
dog him and rapper had a you know you
know katie gave him tickets
you know he gave him tickets when the
all-star game was in mass square garden
he gave rapport tickets so there's
clearly a friendship there
you don't post dm's dude also it's kevin
garnett
besides kevin uh yeah kevin durant
besides lebron talking about the second
biggest star in the nba
you know you know he's gonna [ __ ] his
life up you post that messed up his
brand
messed up his brand it's not smart no
you don't do that i know
it's guy code right you know this dog no
he said i felt very but
even rap knows now like he [ __ ] up man
like he was like i messed up i shouldn't
have done that
because dude the backlash he got back
yeah lawyered up everything
but again you don't like you said geico
you can't disrespect that i don't know
rap personally but i just know geico
rap's a good guy
okay rap's a good guy he just you know
rap talks a lot of [ __ ]
and just got caught up okay but again
you don't do that man that's like skip
bayless
leaking dms from athletes you can't do
that because those athletes they're
playing a different game they're going
to lose sponsorships and money and for
their family and yeah fans and stuff so
like rap you're not
in the same lane as kevin durant thank
you yeah
it's such a bummer and like the way
kevin durant talked i wasn't like
offended
no but that's the way guys talk to each
other like pull up at 10 a.m
they're like they're like racial slurs
it's like yeah no you're lighting each
other up man yeah you caught him he's
like you pale
[ __ ] yeah right yeah but that's that's
how again that's the relationship yeah
that's not for the public yeah we know
kevin
uh got me saying kevin durant he just
like stays on social media
you know but even even both came out was
like dude that was a personal
private oh you know everyone's
discussion
has nothing to do with anyone else but
them yeah it's just a [ __ ] moved by rap
rap said he was gonna pay
he would feel bad he's gonna pay the 50
000 fine it doesn't
that's a nice gesture but think about
all the brands that's gonna
like he lost that weekend you know
maybe white pill hopefully not hopefully
people realize that that's a private
discussion
and any brand that wants to back off
after that like there's
listen i've had something he'll find
he'll he'll be all right any brand that
doesn't want to ride
[ __ ] see you man yeah even he's still
mate
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah i think
he'll be fine all right it's a bummer
though
yeah it was funny
the other conversation yeah
well we talked about this off air um
jimmy found
getting in trouble i didn't see this oh
i was just
talking to like chappelle and malik
about this so
this girl is very very famous what's
your name addison ray
on tick tock so she was on jimmy fallon
and then she did a bunch of these dances
okay what's the problem are you about to
see okay so she does all these different
music
well okay maybe because the band's
playing i could do it
[Music]
first off
this is what she's famous for on tick
tock oh they miss up
right
[Applause]
so basically it's all that stupid i'll
do whatever he can to keep ratings
[Laughter]
but so a lot of the prom a lot of those
dances that she did or maybe all of them
if not
most if not most of them were taken from
other creators
mostly african-american right yeah but
so they don't add their names or
anything and she gets credit for doing
those dances
yeah this is something i already managed
[ __ ] yeah but and also
a little different it's a little
different because there's a culture on
tick tock tick tock is very like
young very woke genziers where
uh they basically a lot of the top tick
talkers happen to be
these very attractive uh younger white
kids so like
white girls white guys who make a living
off of doing these dances
that were traditionally made i think
from minorities specifically black
people
and on tick tock they said hey it's
[ __ ] up that you're doing these dances
and not crediting the person who made
that they do it in the original videos
on tick tock no they didn't
initialize anyone ever uh initially i
think it started becoming like a thing
where they started doing a little later
so maybe like the last few months
but initially no one really did it and
people said it's [ __ ] up because these
kids are making multi millions of
dollars off of dances that they didn't
create and they're saying jason
with the savage love dance
so people are just mad that uh the
original creators aren't getting credit
again
these are the original creators yeah
well jimmy fallon got so much backlash
for it that he actually had someone edit
in those video
uh the credits for the youtube videos
he doesn't know he doesn't know but look
at her up and look at those
ones
oh my god
i can't i can't believe she makes a
living dancing like that yeah oh i guess
how much money she misses what's scary
is this younger generation
i'm sure she's a nice person they don't
have talent yeah they're getting
money for their these talents but that's
oh and that's what they're screaming
like give the credit to the girls that
created at least credit it's a weird
thing yeah i would expect to be credited
to if they're using something
like my music another comparison oh
let me see one more
what a nightmare disaster i go to the
corvette
but also that the corvette corvette
these fans that would keep this same
energy man you're the one that
she's a millionaire because you're
sucking on her tits for the shitty
dancing
oh man i wanted to follow that yeah
yeah yeah it's crazy and a lot of these
tick tockers are now going from tick
tock to youtube
to a lot of them are making music now
and then she's in an upcoming movie
actually a netflix movie
who she's the star of a netflix movie
she's doing the remake uh she's all that
and it's called he's all that
so they're remaking that movie and she's
a star they don't need a remix it's the
original
yes in the original no this is the one
no these are like the popular tick
talkers this is just her tic tocs
not the original people go to the
original uh who is the original
uh no we're looking for like that
comparison yeah i didn't i did
comparison but
these videos are [ __ ] nice see how
bad it was in comparison to the original
dude i don't know i didn't get i mean i
thought
i mean give me credit for the promise
it's not even good it's not even great
i'm not even doing a good
rendering yeah it's so stupid the
rendition is [ __ ] yeah
also i didn't get a uh just the one
that's the main one
is that the only one they did well
that's the only one i found that was so
hilarious
damn i wish they had another one i know
jimmy fallon's just trying so hard to
keep followers yeah i was like
first of all yeah what i mean or you
know she should be on there
yeah you know she has no business beyond
that
that was that was a girl i told you i
saw when i was at crossroads yeah and
paparazzi were
all she's very famous surrounded is she
she is she the biggest take doctor no uh
the biggest is this girl named charlie
demilio she's a 16 year old
she's huge on youtube because tiger
watches her youtube videos yes
they're all huge she's like a large
she's like 30 million views
they have a large fan base with kids
specifically does she have a sister
yes yes so they got in trouble my girl
just shot uh
something with them uh just this past
week
yeah they're they're very very popular
yeah wait they they got it she's 19 the
other one secretly they got she she got
her sister in trouble because they're
mean to the chef
they like put they posted a video of
them eating and then oh like what the
[ __ ]
is this well i thought it was like these
because
it was a scripted video where like her
team knew that this the older sister
dixie
uh she is kind of like you where she
doesn't like to eat a lot of different
things
they knew that they oh okay but there's
certain things that
she just didn't like they made her
snails on camera knowing that she was
gonna have a bad reaction to it
and so her team set it up where oh we're
gonna make her eat something gross and
she's gonna look disgusted
she ended up spitting out the she's like
mean to the chef and she started uh
joking around and saying that i was like
disgusting people thought that it was
like a slap in the face to the chef who
was right there but the chef was in on
that he was in on it
yeah so it's just one of those things
where it's like
i think local culture is coming after
these tick tockers really hard
they can't because they can't dance yeah
i think that's the biggest reason i mean
she did when she did that corvette
corvette oh my god she went to the
original but
dog how bad was she it felt like a lamb
trying to
it's just so weird that that's like what
i mean but what's the
what's the longevity in that just stay
take someone else's idea i don't know
bro no like
i'll talk about it once you run out of
that yeah
because they're so famous people want
their audience because she hangs out
with the kardashians now she's trying to
she's kind of smart where she's
parlaying this tick tock career like
actually being outside
she kind of got popular off of summer
rae though because on tick tock uh when
she was younger she had like similar
hair to summer rae so people thought she
was like
oh your cousin or whatever so summer way
was kind of a part of her fame
i don't know i don't get it it's for the
younger generation i don't get it
absolutely logan paul right i don't know
oh she's a baddie though yeah i mean
that's
that's a tough one yeah but all these
kids made
mil multiple millions of dollars during
that pandemic when everyone was at home
that's how they blew up
as fast as it comes in as quick as it
goes out hopefully they're smart with it
hopefully they're smart what else you
guys that's pretty much it
that's it that's it you want it oh it's
mad as well
we're going to end on bringing we're
looking at bringing arms can you do
this i mean that's what it is that's the
market
anyone just starts here like stealing
your chair routines or something like
that your school like
people i mean at the same time i didn't
give a [ __ ] who's going to look like me
out there on the cheerleading floor yeah
but the routine can look the same i mean
it's all is it but it's like it's like
just what happened here like some people
who someone's going to make it look
better and obviously one
home girl yeah that was kicking it with
fallon you know
so it's like does it even but but also i
think some of the problem is
the demos don't transfer so when you're
on jimmy fallon
that's a much older demo yeah so
remember when drake went super viral
with the
remember that guy created the dance for
drake where that uh oh
yeah kiki and we all we all knew where
it came from so when we saw everyone
doing it they didn't credit homeboy
because they were all in that lane we
all knew that came from that guy
so no one credited him this is a little
different because it's on jimmy fallon's
mainstream tv
they didn't give credit to it but now
they want the credit
but then we don't keep that same energy
over here but but
wait till i miss you know but everything
i didn't i honestly didn't know that
came from somewhere it went
super fast yeah i got a guy made up that
day but he's in the video yeah
he's in the video exactly oh okay yeah
but but then every every
celebrity every youtuber everyone copied
that video but now everyone gave him
credit because we all knew it came from
him
yeah yeah yeah but i guess he knew it
was a rendering but i guess
perfect example junebug you heard about
the junebug challenge where the people
do that that thing that's not his dance
he stole that dance
but he didn't he he took off because
people went to his page
and not the other guy the little 17 year
old so he took off and now he's all over
torn again that's what people like if
you if i don't have a lot of followers
that guy who created
that he already had like 2.3 million so
he was already good
but this guy who created that junebug
yeah now it'd be different if
that girl that addison ray girl brought
them on with her thank you
too fallon be like hey that's that
that's not her responsibility but at
least
it's not it's not but you're right
because how many other people besides
asking ray did that dance
everyone literally everyone everyone
she's just the most famous she's just
the most famous that's not her job
that's what you're saying that's not her
no
it's not that's that's that's the that's
the lane she's in that's not her job
yeah because maybe she didn't see the
original and she was like oh this is
what's trending
all right so she that that and then
jimmy fallon calls and she's like here
you go [ __ ]
that's a fair thing to say that's not
her job
she figured out she feel she probably
never saw the original video that that
is not her job
that's tick tock what are the odds of
every that's what i'm saying i get it
she's going to find the original
everywhere what are the odds that's the
trend
the original
original ice bucket guy like this credit
out to greg in new york
like no it was just this trending thing
that's not her job
yeah it's also not her fault that she's
more famous than all those dancers and
she decided to jump on the trend
like those dancers step your game up
yeah like that that's on you to get
famous
yeah now everyone's like hey patrick
quinn this is for you thanks for the
inspiration for the ice bucket challenge
no [ __ ] it's viral once it goes viral
that then that's just kind of where the
world owns it
yeah it's different if it's a
it's different if it's a joke right
that's your original
creative thought if it's a song original
creative thought um
dance movement i hate to i hate that i
hate it
for sure hate to tell you i would be
willing to bet those two that came up
with the dance
got it from somewhere i bet you they
didn't create i bet all those movements
have been done before
it's not like we saw that like oh this
is the matrix you're absolutely right
there's like
certain uh like tick-tock dance
movements and they kind of like they're
all very similar
it's an algorithm where it all looks
very similar
yeah but that was all the dancers all
the dancers do pretty much look the same
look the same
yeah okay and if you think those two
those two girls that obviously way
better dancers but
you're crazy if you don't think they're
inspired by something else that caused
them to do that and then that
went viral everything yeah we all get
inspiration from
everything you know so i don't think
listen if you're an intern alison ray's
probably
she can't dance like that but she has
the most faith that's why that's why
it's such a tough look for her because
it's not even a tough look it's just
like you guys want to create this
monster i've been doing these dances
forever i don't know what the [ __ ] made
them it's a trend that's tick tock i do
trends [ __ ]
like you want me to go find the original
well where did they get it
yeah sure they made it up they didn't
make that up
but they probably made up a maybe
something maybe a movement
but the majority of we've seen before
that ain't mind-blowing i've seen [ __ ]
like that
yeah what about okay it's a perfect
example the whip it remember the whippet
that whipped dance that's very popular
what's the whipping the whippet
like whip it yeah like the they do this
that
oh that's the whoa the whoa my bad the
whoa came off us
apologize came off the song everything
made it popular
right so it's very popular they added
they add that in
every dance now so so should he be upset
that he made up that we never seen that
belongs to the streets you put that
energy out there that belongs to the
streets it goes viral
you get notoriety out there going viral
like oh that's homeboy
but that belongs to the streets yeah you
can't trademark that
that movement yeah yeah because you
can't really like there's certain things
you can't do that well you can't do that
with like
music you can't do that with comedy you
know we just can't do it like a movie
straight to dancing but yeah but like in
a dancing world like it's that viral
world
once you put it on that viral world like
unless it's like a
saying because that okay that's also the
thing people want it to be this viral
that's why
that's why they do it so when you put
that out there
that's what happens you know i i get
what you're saying
once you upload to youtube yeah you make
it like a
yeah like you created a trend yeah and
that's on you to capitalize it from
there
yeah but but they're basically just the
most famous who's
that how do you want to give her all
this [ __ ] but how many tick talkers
don't give credit to the original
a lot that's what that's what that's
that's what they do that's what i think
and now you can
keep the same energy with every tick
tocker that does a trend thing
oh you didn't quote the original ongoing
i guarantee you asked 99.9 i'm like i
don't know it was a trend i looked up
looks dope
i have a following so i do it yeah
that's another that's their business
model
well don't you think like after a while
that's just a i mean
it's just an ongoing battle like you're
just gonna keep battling
this thing where it's like you kind of
threw it out there i think addison ray's
problem is she went off the youtube
platform i'm sorry tick tock platform
then went to major tv and start doing it
and it seems like that's where the
people had the problem
yeah you know because she's it's not her
issue
it's not belongs to the street yeah and
that's on jimmy fallon
because they couldn't they could have
called her out on tick tock like hey why
are you doing this dance but it belongs
to this point tick-tock straight
straight yeah but when you take it
the next tv then it's like hey you took
that
technically yeah you're right she she
did it how many other people took it
it's just now i'm on nbc and now you
want to
tell them stealing [ __ ] yeah because
she's doing the exact same thing she did
on tick tock but now she's
on balance show so shouldn't the
responsibility then like
it's on the writers and bookers yeah
that's yeah that's awesome she's just
like dude i don't i do these trends
yeah i just do trends where'd it come
from and it's honestly it's not even
like she was saying like she came up
with them
she wasn't even she just did that's
different she came out they're like
these are original takes but
yeah you create all this it does it
doesn't seem i don't i don't
[ __ ] i'm not i haven't watched fallon
i don't think ever but um
you know i don't know that's why i don't
think she was going out there saying
like yeah i did this [ __ ] this
this [ __ ] mine and then she didn't
mention it yeah she realized she just
did the dance
look back at the channel how old is she
17 she's 19
20. i mean come on she's young yeah
she's young yeah so it's like
the streets
20 years old she's 20 years old no dude
she's from lafayette oh louisiana hell
yeah she was not wrong at all
y'all been crazy it's blown to the
streets
movements along the streets yeah i'm
with that is that it china i actually
have one more forgot
okay oh okay uh this former this former
raiders
offensive tackle do you know this guy
bruce campbell uh apparently he's
not a former wrestler oh man i heard
this is fake but keep going okay well
if it was him he was trying to like he
was arguing with another guy the other
guy just jacked him up
oh this [ __ ] was crazy i didn't see it i
didn't watch it either oh it's a good
fight
all right is it real well i mean if
brendan already said that
i just saw some articles it's not him
but who knows
but this is a real fight yeah so he's
like six four three hundred something
pounds why is he mad they want to wear a
mask
i can't hear him i don't know why they
got the argument you can't really hear
but i just know the other dude's trying
to walk away yeah but i do look a little
gangster this isn't
he just keeps yelling [ __ ] at him been
scrapping something
dude looks like he's gonna pull out the
blick
[Music]
yeah you're too big not to be able to
learn how to fight man the green mile
got it
can't fight it the great mile got his
ass off he can't fight at
all talking all that [ __ ] he can't fight
damn if you're right brent it's not yeah
i'd be mad if i was bruce campbell
it wasn't me yeah i'm on my channel i'm
with my kids
i draw good yeah we egg hunting this
[ __ ]
you have your you have your baby in your
hand yeah don't even look like him
no the kid's all around you bruce so
there is this story
that is out there right now that is
saying that you were in an altercation
in a walmart oh so same name but it's
just not him
broken and it happens to be a big dude
that's you were you in a fight in a
walmart
no that was not me no i did not get my
jaw broken
um as you can see right now i'm just
just being
enjoying fatherhood man enjoying
fatherhood
of my next career as a coach and just
just trying to
get my next career going the idea why
people have said this is you or where
this
came from um
i have i have no idea i do not
and he still got his receipt checked at
the end that's it he knocked him down
three times all right man the squad win
naples florida next week thursday friday
saturday naples florida april 15th
through the 17th
in austin texas tickets are selling out
fast so we might add some shows austin
so don't stress
april 22nd through 24th vulcan gas
company theater austin texas right off
sixth street there
the whole squad will be there and
special guest and then just announced
houston texas may 20th through the 22nd
houston texas
houston improv to get to f a t k z dot
com
nate will see you next week awesome the
week after see you soon
we love you guys we're out boom boom all
right
what hey how are we doing my name is
raphael lacy
fo honey that's where i got this shirt
this yg snoop dogg collab oh
i don't know something while we were
walking back what did that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hat rolly boy boogie
i'm over here eating this weed that was
a lot it was a lot
i got the yeezys on these boots i know
i've been wearing these a lot lately
you know i don't know yeah
you know i like welcome to the good life
i smoke the good
i roll the one ferrari
yo hey man step in there
what they doing
naples austin see you soon